the comedian john lovitz is joining a
chorus of entertainers speaking out
against
cancel culture and while his heart is in
the right place
his argument is weak in a recent
interview lovett said the cancel culture
is no different than mccarthyism
but that isn't true there are lots of
differences between cancer culture
and mccarthyism most notably the fact
that cancer culture
is bad that would be a big difference
conservatives have spent a long time
saying yes to the left to the
libertarians to the libertines to the
foreign nationals to the multinationals
to other nations and worst of all to the
radicals who want to upend our entire
way of life
if we want to win if we want to at least
stop
losing conservatives need to learn to
say
no cnn is trying to mainstream another
sexual deviant
the squishes are defending critical race
theory and the federal reserve is trying
to cancel the founding fathers
what do we say to that just say
no i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
just say knowles
no nols nos i don't know maybe there's a
relation
my favorite comment yesterday from josh
kelly who says man
i bet putin is steaming biden just
called him
a worthy adversary i'll give biden one
thing
he sure knows how to hit a man below the
belt i know thank you for picking up on
this
this is one of the most preposterous
claims of the left
amid many preposterous claims they claim
that babies aren't babies they claim
that men are women
and yet one of the most preposterous
claims they make is that they're the
ones that are tough on russia
they just spent a century sucking up to
russian communists
at every turn covering up for russian
communists in their newspapers
trying to create alliances with them
politically trying to pursue de taunt
with them
and now republicans are the ones who
collude with russia
absolutely preposterous you know it's
important to have a strong memory
it's important to remember what happened
in the past and if you want to preserve
your past
you got to check out legacy box legacy
box is a super simple mail-in service to
have all your video tapes camcorder
tapes film reels and pictures digitally
preserved on a thumb drive
dvd or the cloud you've got
tapes you've got photos they are
wasting away they are becoming very
degraded preserve them
digitally legacy box is a great way for
you to easily and affordably do that the
process is so simple from start to
finish you pack and send
their team digitizes everything by hand
you enjoy legacy box is the world's
largest
digitizer of home movies and photos it's
helped over 850 000 families digitally
preserve their past
we are conservatives at least in my
household we like
our past we like to think about our
history we want to preserve that
toward the future win the favorite kid
award this father's day
with legacy box get started preserving
your family's legacy today
go to legacybox.com knowles to get an
incredible 50
off your first order buy today to take
advantage of this exclusive offer send
it in when you're ready
legacy box great for you or someone you
love legacy box.com and i'll save 50
while supplies last cancel culture is
just like mccarthyism no it's not
if you want to hear a
strong defense of joe mccarthy and
mccarthyism and anti-communism you can
check that out in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available for pre-order for one more
week
one more week and then the book will be
coming out i feel like i've been
shilling this book
for approximately 15 years now but it is
finally coming out there is still a very
limited amount of time to get
your signed first edition copy through
pre-order at premiere collectibles
that would be one big difference
obviously cancel culture is different
than mccarthyism
for one example the people who are being
cancelled are very different
the views that are being canceled are
very different one view
pretty pro-american one view pretty
anti-american john levitt says
we can't do that he says quote as soon
as you say to a comedian like me you
can't say that the first thing in my
head is
oh and now i have to okay you'll hear a
lot of comedians say this and it makes
perfect sense you push boundaries
you say things that are taboo and
incongruous and that gets a laugh
but does that mean that you should just
be able to say whatever you want at any
time for
without any question or limitation not
even john lovett says that in his very
next breath
he says oh yeah and now i have to i've
got to say the thing you tell me i can't
say
but but there's a difference between
making jokes and being
outright mean so he's saying even for
him even for a comedian
there are limits to what he will say of
course there are always limits
every society has taboos the question is
not do you have taboos or do you not
have taboos
that's a that's a stupid question
because we're always going to have to
we're always going to say some things
are off limits i know
that there are some idealistic utopian
libertarian i don't know what term you
want to use who say no there's no limits
whatsoever but it's just
silly that's not true that has never
been true that never will be true
even the comedians are admitting there
are limits so what are
those limits going to be over in
iowa the governor has just banned
critical race theory there have been
multiple bans you've seen in florida
you've seen it in a lot of places right
now
critical race theory kim reynolds
governor of iowa signed that bill
that that says that if you teach in such
a way as to
assign fault blame or bias to a race or
sex or to members of a race or sex
because of their race or sex
you can't do that in the classroom good
stuff i strongly support that
critical race theory of course a
derivation of critical theory which is a
huge part
of the politically correct slash woke
project that has brought us to our
current state
of censorship which you can read about
in my opinion book speech just
controlling words growing minds which is
available now for pre-order
the point here is we need to
dig in it's not enough to say yes you
say this yes you do that yes whatever
you want we're the party of freedom
freedom much like poetry requires
limitations that's where the freedom and
the flourishing
comes from now there are some misguided
conservatives and former conservatives
who are saying this is terrible you've
got to be very careful
you shouldn't be banning critical race
theory in the classroom the founding
fathers
are rolling over in their graves first
of all the founding fathers banned
all this sorts of stuff okay let's not
forget within just a few years of the
existence of our republic
our second president and one of our most
conservative presidents john adams
passed the alien and sedition acts which
criminalized making false statements
about the federal government
parts of those laws still exist today a
lot of it was
was gotten rid of but some of it still
exists today there are
all sorts of laws that have prescribed
this kind of speech
but now we are to believe that critical
race theory is just the sort of thing
that americans must defend
of course you're hearing this from
people such as david french who
are former republicans or former
conservatives who are now
i don't know how david would describe
himself now but he spends most of his
time you'll notice
criticizing people on the right um
you're also hearing this though
from quite serious conservative
professors
i'm thinking of robbie george at
princeton who has been a conservative
leader
for many years he's done very good work
i don't agree with him on everything but
he's done very good work he tweeted out
quote
and it would seem that this is in direct
response to the critical race theory
bans he tweeted out
it's quite simple no view or school of
thought
is banned no view or school of thought
is given a monopoly formerly or
informally or immunized from criticism
views and schools of thought are
defended and criticized by giving
reasons providing evidence or making
arguments
that is simply not true that is not true
i can't tell if if robbie george
knows that this is not true but is
trying to carve out some space in the
university for conservative points of
view he's done a very good job of that
at princeton
so maybe he's trying to pretend that
what he just said is true
so that the liberals are more likely to
give him some space to run for instance
the james madison program
or or to hire more conservative faculty
members i don't know if that's the case
tactically it's probably smart
but as a an objective matter what he
just said is not true there are plenty
of views that are completely off limits
that are there are plenty of views
they're given a monopoly actually
in various institutions uh and and
all those views tend to just be
derivations of the broader
leftist ideology many of them some are
immune
immunized from criticism and some are
prohibited as
bill buckley famously stated in god and
man at yale the yale
department of sociology would never hire
an aryan supremacist
to teach about the glories of white
people
in the university nor should they that
the university would not do that they
should not do that
that view is prohibited many many views
are prohibited from the university
as they must be the university has a
mission all
classrooms have a mission they teach
some things and by teaching some things
they exclude other things
if you teach the two plus two equals
four you are necessarily teaching the
two plus two does not equal
five this is true history philosophy
religion
ethics science everything
okay now interestingly
i think david french makes the the more
sophisticated criticism here
of the critical race theory bans he's
saying look some of these critical race
theory bands are so broad
that you're going to end up shooting
yourself in the foot and banning speech
that even you would support so some of
the critical race theory bands are
creating
uh protections from from criticism in
the classroom for
religions for other things that are that
are
creeds whatever that means so if you
have a protection for a creed is that
protecting communism from criticism
obviously we wouldn't want to do that so
i actually agree with david french's
criticism there
you want to be very specific we're not
banning from the classroom all sorts of
criticism of all sorts of things
we are specifically banning this radical
stupid ugly false
theory called critical race theory which
is a derivation of the broader critical
theory product
project what is critical race theory we
all use this term
and yet people don't seem to know what
it means
well you can read the academic
literature on it it's developed by this
woman kimberly crenshaw
or a number of other people who've
contributed to this particular
subset of critical theory but it's
probably easier just to watch a video on
what critical theory looks like
in action here is ashley shackleford a
quote
queer agender black fat femme writer
artist and cultural producer she is
giving a lesson
through the analytical lens of critical
race theory to a group of deluded and
poor white people i think it's sort of a
mixed mixed crowd here
this is what crt looks and sounds like
in practice
white people are racist so i put this up
because i really want
any white person in the room to know up
front that this is what we're dealing
with
that it's not going to be this coddling
of white tears
and what that looks like we're not going
to discuss oh maybe some of us have
worked it out
no you're always going to be racist
actually so even when you're on your
path to trying to figure out how to be a
better human being
um because i believe that white people
are born into not being human
like that actually instead of people of
color and black folks being dehumanized
that actually everyone is dehumanized
off-grid within white supremacy
that y'all are born into a life to not
be human and that's what y'all are
taught to do
to be demons so in this particular way
why people are all racist there you have
it
there's the lesson did you take notes i
hope you took notes so that you can
crumple them up and throw them in the
fire this sort of stuff
is not just valueless this sort of woman
doesn't just have
nothing of value to say this sort of
stuff
is bad for your brain it's bad for your
mind it's
anti-education it's making you dumber
and less well-behaved and less
sophisticated
it needs to be banned from the classroom
like you would ban
poison from your recipes it is so
so stupid there is no free marketplace
first of all
there is no free marketplace of ideas in
the classroom period
that's a hoax that's a farce another
insight of william f buckley jr
people set the curricula the harvard law
professor adrian vermeel just pointed
this out the other day he said
for the love of god people the high
school classroom is not the free
marketplace of ideas
it's a place to convey certain
information and to convey education a
coercive
act with curricula that are set by
school boards and by politicians and by
administrators
it is not the this free-flowing place of
debate that's not how it works in
practice it's not even how it works
in theory you need you need
to say no i know we only want to say yes
and be the nice inclusive guys
to something like critical race theory
to all white people are racist in their
demons
you have to say no
now when you do want a thriving
marketplace especially for auto
auto parts i would strongly recommend
checking out rockauto.com rockauto.com
is so much easier than walking into a
store and someone demanding quick
answers to things like hey
is your car a zt 72 2018
or a px i don't know i don't know i
don't know what kind of car mic
i have a grey car that's my car what do
you go then they go into the back
they don't have any of the parts anyway
they go online they go to rockauto.com
and then they charge you twice as much
right i think that's what happens
that's i i would imagine skip that skip
go on over to rockauto.com
right now this is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers with a catalog
so simple and easy to navigate even i
can do it they got the same prices for
pros like me and do-it-yourselfers like
you
they don't vary the price day by day
with some gimmicky nonsense
always reliably low stuff head on over
to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write null scanner
wles in there how did you hear about
xbox
so that they know we sent you what is
being taught
in our classrooms not just
elementary middle high school not just
certain kooky
universities what is being taught
in the ivy league what is supposed to be
the pinnacle the elite of american
education
is so radical
that a defector from north korea
has been scandalized by the brainwashing
in those classrooms
so i went to columbia university in 2016
and i
transferred from south korean university
so when i was
at school though you know i was excited
about like learning about
his story and you know how the people
thought back then
and one of the person that organization
was asking
who's like loves jane austen and
and who reads this classical books and i
was like i love those books i just said
i thought it was a good thing right and
then she was like
did you know that those writers who had
a colonial mindset
were racist and bigots wrote their books
so they are
subconsciously brainwashing you and
that's like
when i realized wow this is insane
i'm like i literally thought i thought
america was that
different and i just saw so much
similarity that i saw in north korea
and i was starting worrying about this
country mainstream education
is purposefully designed to not make
resentments western democracy
so pretty startling observations
from a korea from the most repressive
regime on earth who says good grief man
this place is pretty bad at the
university this woman has survived
the most deluded brainwashed regime on
the planet and she says man this
brainwashing at the universities really
gives
old kim jong-un a run for his money and
that's true
now what she i think fails to recognize
is what it's the same mistake that so
many
conserve they tend to be the squishy
types of conservatives fail to recognize
which is they say this typical
expression
we shouldn't teach students what to
think we should teach them how to think
sure but you can't teach someone how to
think
unless you teach them what to think you
can't teach them how to think about
calculus
if you don't teach them that 2 plus 2
equals four to get back to our earlier
example
you can't teach them how to think about
history until you teach them
that america declares dependence in 1776
and the civil war breaks out in 1860 and
ronald reagan gets elected in 1980 you
can't
tell them how to think about these
things until you tell them certain facts
about it when you tell them facts you're
stating this is true
and this is false here is what you
should think
that's a fact figure it out get used to
it
or keep losing ground a topic i discuss
at red length in my upcoming book
speechless controlling worth controlling
mine's only
only seven more days of pre-order oh my
gosh
there is always going to be a
perspective
there was always going to be a bias now
sometimes that perspective is closer to
the truth
sometimes that perspective is farther
away from the truth
sometimes there are different
perspectives on the same event
and they have considerable or comparable
value
sometimes one perspective is correct and
one perspective
is incorrect i'll give you an example of
bias
because it's not just at in some
classroom at brown university it's a
it's in the federal reserve for goodness
sakes the federal reserve
has now discouraged the use
of offensive words such as
wait for it founding fathers
no not the n word not the this word not
that i mean i assume those are banned
too
but no the f word the two f words
founding fathers the federal reserve
now says no bueno
quote try to avoid words and phrases
that may be considered offensive
pejorative or prejudiced
whatever that the transformation of the
word prejudice from something that is
actually quite good and reliable in the
sense used by edmund burke to this awful
evil terrible thing
is an amazing transformation in and of
itself
but they say these words can distract
your audience from the ideas or
information you're trying to convey
the bias terms to be avoided include
blacklist
can't do that it's offensive to black
people grandfathered
that you can't do that that's a racist
term too how we would need some more
time to describe
that silliness and founding fathers
also instead of that you should use
terms like denied instead of blacklist
legacy instead of grandfather and
founders instead of founding fathers
because if you said founding fathers
that would imply
that virtually all of the founders were
men and
that's true but it's offensive
apparently so you're not allowed to say
it
the fed also says that the terms
whitelisted it's bad it's racist
manpower sexist man-made sexist even
though man is a
gender-neutral term in the beginning god
created man both male and female he
created them nope not allowed to say
that
uh singular generic pronouns are to be
avoided
so if you say hey i like john he's a
nice guy
boom nope sorry time to come in for
re-education
you should say according to them
they to refer to one person i like john
they is a nice person you're supposed to
say that unless you
speak like somebody who's who has never
taken an english class in his life
you are apparently giving offense why
so that you don't convey bias
in your language
you know when i read these terms these
new terms that the fed wants to use
they seem pretty biased to me
the bias especially on the singular use
of they
the bias being against grammar it's
anti-grammar
it's nonsense supremacist the bias
being in favor of radical gender
ideology that says that there's no
difference between men and women
the bias being in favor of this radical
idea that america is a wicked awful
terrible sexist racist
whatever place that's a bias
that's a radical bio so let's try to get
the bias out of that language how could
you do it
you're not allowed to use the one term
because it's biased you're not allowed
to use the other term because it's
biased there's always going to be
it would seem some kind of perspective
conveyed
there is no such thing as neutrality
that is the
the worst error that the squishes have
foisted on us over the last 15 or 20
years
is the lie that secular liberalism
is somehow a neutral playing field on
which conservatives and the left and the
right and the left they can just
sort of equally duke it out no we're
playing on the left's ground we're
accepting
all of their most important premises so
no wonder that we're going to lose and
unfortunately
many of the squishes i think would
prefer to lose they feel much better
about
losing with dignity they say they're
very undignified
they feel better about that because they
don't need to take on any moral risk
because they
they don't exhibit courage
but there's always going to be some kind
of bias and it's never going to end
the revolution is going to eat itself
even
tom hanks tom hanks
once the most trusted best best liked
man in the country
according to polls is cancelled
he is or they're at least trying to
cancel them tom hanks is a super
lib super duper lib raises money for
democrats he just recently just a couple
of weeks ago
wrote an erotic essay for the new york
times about the tulsa race riot
and how white people need to feel bad or
something
but he's not he's not anti-racist the
left contends
he's not racist but he's not anti-racist
and frankly if you ask me that's just as
bad
as being a racist racehorse i don't even
know i don't even know what that means
anymore now
in the author's defense the author who
accused
tom tom hanks rather of not being
anti-racist
tom hanks is the father of chet hanks
and chet hanks
did formally declare white boy summer
hey guys um look i just wanted to tap in
really quick i just got this feeling man
um that this summer is uh
it's about to be a white boy summer you
know
take it how you want i'm not talking
about like trump uh
you know nascar type white i'm talking
about you know
you know me um john b
jack harlow type white boy summer you
know what i mean let me know if you guys
uh
can vibe with that and uh get ready you
know
because i am yeah i am too chet i man
chet
sign me up i don't do i count i don't
know i'm a little especially during the
summer i get quite quite dark so i
if i can be vibin with you and mr harlow
and
then absolutely sign me up watching that
video
i i do wonder
have chet and tom hanks ever spoken to
one another can you imagine can you just
close your eyes and imagine a situation
in which chet and tom angs have a
conversation because
i i can't imagine that but i would very
much like to
it is it would be a very funny company
so anyway okay
chet hanks the founder of white boy
summer is uh
tom's son but that's not why that is not
the reason
that the left is angry at tom hanks for
not being
anti-racist the reason is that in his
career his
gigantic long-lasting film career tom
hanks has played white people
who do the right thing you know when
you want to make sure that you protect
your home from people who want to do the
wrong thing
you got to check out ring there are
thousands of reasons why protecting
your home should matter to you here's
one for me my cute little newborn baby
jun little june and sweet little alisa i
want to make sure that she's protected
and sometimes i'm on the road so i want
to be able to check in at my house
i want my wife to be able to check in
and know who is on the doorstep
before she opens the door and you know
what helps you do that
ring ring can protect every
inch of your house and you can see and
speak to as ever on your doorstep
whether you are in the house whether you
are at the office
whether you are on the road in the
middle of the country that
is what ring will give you it is frankly
just peace of mind
and great stuff to give you peace of
mind and for your friends you know if
your friend is moving into a new home
nice housewarming gift a nice father's
day gift
very impressive stuff will keep your
friends and family safe and most
importantly not that expensive so it
will save you
money and you'll get to give a very good
product to get the ring alarm for
yourself go to ring.com
knowles to start your ring experience
ring.com
slash knowles you can build the system
yourself have it up and running
in minutes that is ring.com
knowlesring.com
knowles if you want to read about
authoritarianism you got to check out
ben's new book
the authoritarian moment that is the
title of ben's new book
and also the slogan of my future
political campaign the authoritarian
moment
ben tells you how we got here as a
society how we can fight back it's a
great book to pre-order
right after you pre-order speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is
very good it's really good as a second
pre-order at amazon barnes and noble or
any other major bookseller also my
friend georgia howe
has a new show office hours it's
available as a podcast
from discussing critical race theory
with james lindsay to transgenderism
with abigail schreier her show
offers a wealth of incredible
information from some of america's most
important voices
subscribe and download office hours with
georgia howe on apple podcasts or
whatever
your platform of choice may be go check
it out we'll be right back with a lot
more
this article going around saying that
tom hanks is not
an anti-racist that is why the left is
upset with him right now
this is the thesis this is his big
transgression
quote over the years tom hanks has
starred in a lot of big movies about
historical events including saving
private ryan greyhound forrest gump
apollo 13
bridge of spies and news of the world he
has served as a producer executive
producer on even more films and tv shows
based on american history including band
of brothers
the pacific john adams and from the
earth to the moon he was an executive
producer of documentaries such as the
assassination of president kennedy
and the 60s on cnn in other words
he is a baby boomer star who has built a
sizeable part of his career
on stories about american white men
doing the right thing
and that that's the problem apparently
apparently right now in our culture
it is not permissible to believe
that white men can do the right thing
because this apparently erases that's
the that's the verb they like
it erases black voices and the voices of
women
and do you remember some years ago now
not that long ago
there was the daniel day-lewis lincoln
movie
and this was protested by people on the
far left
because it suggested that abraham
lincoln freed the slaves
which obviously he did but they didn't
like that
because the far left said no no the
slaves freed themselves you're erasing
the contributions
of black people and women and i don't
know whoever tibetans i don't think they
were involved but it's got to be
everybody other than a white guy
and it's just not true abraham lincoln
freed the slaves he did it it was him
it was basically only him it was him and
all the soldiers overwhelmingly white
who he called into battle that's what
happened that's a nice thing isn't that
in a
in a society where
we think about our past we think about
our future we're bound together as
countrymen
isn't that a nice thing to say one group
of people did a thing for another group
of people
but we're not allowed to believe that
anymore because everything has to be
focused only on one the tyranny of our
own will
and our own ability to save ourselves
without accepting grace from anybody
else
and everything has to be about vicious
racism and division
and no group of people can ever do
anything to another group for another
group of people
tom hanks canceled at least according to
the far left he'll probably survive it
he's powerful enough but
the the thesis i think is much more
widespread
kevin hart pointed this out
how silly this is i guess on the topic
of cancel culture because kevin hart
famously was going to host the oscars
and then they dug up some gay joke he
made 10 years ago and apparently
kevin hart you know is the only comedian
who ever made a gay joke
right i mean i know that statistically
100 of everyone who's ever lived has
made a gay joke but
kevin hart a professional comedian not
allowed to do that
so they asked him from the oscars and he
was a victim of cancelled culture
without question
and he said if people want to pull up
stuff go back to the same old tweets
same tweets of old go ahead there is
nothing i can do you're looking at a
younger version of myself a comedian
trying to be funny and at that attempt
failing i don't know that he was failing
sometimes he failed sometimes he didn't
sometimes the jokes were offensive
sometimes they were less offensive some
of the jokes that were
offensive that are offensive today that
weren't then are no longer funny and
some of them are
comedy is a complicated thing apologies
were made i understand now how it comes
off i look back and cringe so it's
growth it's about growth here's the
money line
when did we get to a point where life
was supposed to be perfect
where people were supposed to operate
perfectly all the time i don't
understand
i don't expect perfection from my kids i
don't expect it from my wife and friends
and employees because last i checked
the only way you grow up is effing up i
don't know a kid who hasn't f'd up or
done some dumb
stuff of course of course he's right
we got to the point where everybody had
to be perfect
when we abandoned christianity as our
motivating religion in this country all
societies have religious views
that also is inevitable just like the
inevitability of standards in our speech
the inevitability of some kind of
religious view is
an eternal fact of of society
you can take that one to the bank okay
and when we gave up on
the christian understanding of of human
nature and
of society and of our eternal
selves then everybody had to be perfect
because then we couldn't make sense of
original sin
we've transformed the idea of original
sin into this idea of white supremacy or
racism
which is just a very stupid way of
talking about original sin i mean you
hear this that people will say this
explicitly
the president of the united states will
say slavery and racism is america's
original sin and that's just not true
original sin is america's original sin
and slavery is
a bad thing that happened that was
rectified
sooner here than in most other places
and it existed here for a shorter period
of time
than virtually anywhere else on earth
and it continues to exist outside of
western civilization
but we are told this is a uniquely
american prize it's just silly
the reason that we think that though is
because we no longer have a way of
grappling with the fact that we are not
perfect
we are flawed the things we want to do
we do not do the things that we don't
want to do we do
because of sin and temptation and the
fallenness of man we
keep trying to deny that we're trying to
deny death which is the consequence of
sin
we're trying to become first of all
we've all become neurotic health nuts
but we're also trying to deny the
possibility of death you hear all of
these futurists talk about how we're
going to upload our brains to the clouds
and
live forever and massively extend our
lives i think it's a fool's errand but
even if you could do it
even if you could find immortality on
earth i wouldn't want it
because my view is still you know that
that old christian view every ancient
ever knew
but because we've lost that now
everybody's got to be perfect
and yet you'll notice well
everybody can get canceled and a great
many people do get canceled
some chosen few the anointed the elect
of the
the liberal ruling establishment
get a second life they they get
they get a whole new a whole new career
a whole new life
such as katie hill so just just this
week cnn
is rehabilitating two sexual deviants
two of the most
prominently exposed as it were sexual
deviants in the country
jeffrey toobin that was yesterday
and katie hill katie hill was caught
having in a throuple so throuple you
know
she was in a kind of menage with her
husband
then husband and one of her staffers and
it wasn't
we talk about a totally consensual thing
first of all if it were a man having an
affair with his staffer
that would be massive news especially if
that man were a republican
huge abuse of power it would be called
intrinsically sexual harassment
intrinsically compromising consent but
because it's katie hill and she's a
liberal woman she gets a pass for it but
then
the staffer woman was apparently really
hurt by this whole thing and especially
when katie hill broke it off
and it was just it was very very ugly
even by the standards of
ordinary affairs and and
sexual impropriety so katie hill got she
got booted she had to resign from
congress now she wants to
to run again she's trying to cast
herself as the victim
and cnn is helping her along you have
been
leading an effort uh since
you left congress to deal with the issue
of revenge porn
uh and uh on the violence against women
act
and really these issues all together
about what
women endure and should not endure will
you run again
listen i i haven't written anything off
um the last two years have
well year and a half have been really uh
you know
tragic and important for my family and
for me
in terms of figuring out what the next
steps are and right now
i i need to figure out my
role in making sure that this gets
passed um helping women
run run for and get elected to office
literally none of that doesn't
make you want to get back in the arena
you know i
s sometimes but sometimes i wonder you
know maybe my role is more important
on the outside so i'm i'm still
definitely on that kind of
you know figuring it out so katie hill
is making herself out to be the victim
of some great injustice
the injustice she says that she was a
victim of
is being exposed for committing
injustices
it's got it's an amazing trick you got
to be a pretty slick politician
to pull this one we need to stop
this revenge porn whatever revenge porn
is if your boyfriend has photos of you
or your husband i guess in this case
has compromising photos of you that they
shouldn't be released of course it's
very wrong to release these sorts of
things
but we have to recognize you shouldn't
be
doing these sorts of things either it's
not
the the injustice is not just that the
husband
exposed katie hill in many ways for
having this affair with her staffer the
injustice is that she had the affair
but that's her private life michael now
it's the same issue with jeffrey toobin
the problem is not just that he did it
in public
the problem is is that he did it in
private too
and we need to be willing to say no
to certain kinds of private behavior
that are destructive and that harm
individuals and that harm society i know
we're not allowed to say that anymore
the simplest one the lowest hanging
fruit
would be porn and not just revenge porn
not just child porn not just other forms
of illegal porn
that are currently illegal porn
in general the sort of stuff that
jeffrey toobin may have taken a look or
two at
in this country we have always had laws
against porn we still have them there
are
obscenity laws as recently as 2009 a
federal judge
sent a pornographer to the clink for
four years almost
just for obscenity that's it he didn't
commit any other crime
he wasn't convicted of any other crime
just for being so obscene he got sent to
the clink
that's good the the people who
are clamoring to regulate or
ban porn outright you think it's some
old fuddy duddy right it's not it's gen
z it's not even the millennials it's gen
z
it's this younger generation where the
millennials at least got to grow up
at least for some period of time without
internet porn all over the place
gen z did not gen z has had devices in
their hands since they were three years
old
and many have written into this show i
mean you've heard it in the mail bag and
elsewhere
of people saying michael i'm 18 years
old and porn has ruined my life they're
the ones calling
they have an experience of it the
private actually has
some role and the squishy or very often
boomer conservatives
will say well look you know we're just
the party of yes we're the party of yes
do whatever you want just don't make me
pay for it
you know okay you can do whatever sick
crazy katie hill jeffrey toobin style
stuff you want to do to yourself
just don't make me pay for it but that's
a very shallow political philosophy it
has very little to do
with the broader conservative tradition
and it clearly has not worked it's just
a purely
political matter we've lost ground on
basically every major issue in my
lifetime
maybe the answer is to start saying no
see how crazy this is speaking of girls
of ill repute
there's a high school in sacramento
california the performing and fine arts
high school
they apparently had something of a dress
code it wasn't like you have to wear
these uniforms it was just a little bit
of a dress code saying
you can't wear clothing that is too
provocative and you can't
be exposing yourself all the time that's
that's wrong
so a tick talk has gone viral we won't
play the tick tock i don't i
i might have legal issues if i play the
stick talk i don't know what i have i
haven't seen it i have the cops are
watching i don't know i haven't clicked
any links
i don't want to watch this but this sort
of thing is going viral
okay and the protest leader
says the school principal was going to
have an assembly on dress code
so in response we wore crop tops to
protest
it was a day-long process we showed up
in crop tops and they started
dressing dress coding people the dress
code is sexist toward women and
perpetuates rape culture
it makes us very uncomfortable we as
students feel like what we wear is not
distracting toward others or affecting
anyone's learning environment so i'm
being only slightly hyperbolic about
what these girls were wearing they
weren't wearing anything that would be
considered illegal
right they weren't totally exposing
themselves they were just wearing
clothing
that is distracting for high school boys
i say this is a former high school boy
okay
and so the school came in and said no
you can't do that you gotta cover your
midriff you gotta
you can't can't do that sort of stuff
what this girl is saying here we as
students feel like what we wear is not
distracting toward others
her perception is just simply false it
is
okay i actually remember this yoga pants
were really popular when i was in high
school
and i remember i was sitting there
taking some standardized tests and i
women were where the girls were wearing
yoga pants and i thought
this is an unfair advantage for women on
this test they're going to do better
on this test than men because all the
boys are going to be distracted by the
girls wearing the clothing that's very
provocative
and the girls aren't going to be
distracted by us we're not you know
we're not
exactly uh you know attracting their
attention right now that's an unfair
advantage and of course this is true
in all of it's just like the free speech
issue
no so what these girls were wearing is
not against the law but there are
standards and you have the right to
enforce standards
this is true of clothing this is true of
what you say this is
this is true of how we live we need
certain boundaries
those are inevitable there's always
going to be some kind of boundary the
question is
who is going to set them the
consequence of the radical sexual
ideologies not just the radical race
ideology that you see in critical race
theory but there's a radical sexual
ideology on campus the consequence of
that
is not clarity it's not discovery it's
not education
it's confusion there's very another sad
tick tock going around
of a gal with dyed hair covered in a
rainbow flag
who's got a bullhorn and who knows looks
like the middle of nowhere with some
friends around her
saying that she has just discovered just
this month that she is actually a boy
this is kind of scary because i only
realized this a couple of days ago and
i've only come out to a few people
i'm a guy
and i'm gonna go by
[Applause]
i theo my mom today and i have to go
home
every day and be called my dead name
and have she her pronouns used every
time i go home
and no one realizes how hurtful it is
it's like a slap in the face
and i dyed my hair last night so i could
feel more masculine
and i was afraid i was going to get
thrown out of the house we love you theo
i'm i'm a guy now yay what a strange i
was just thinking what a strange
fact of feminism that feminism has
convinced high school girls
you know the ones with the dress code to
just wear really skimpy outfits
that'll show the patriarchy we're just
gonna wear skimpy outfits
yeah take that boys oh you got us wow
ouch stop it no please no more
but that's also convinced women that the
the
greatest way that they can express the
why am woman hear me roar
is to just become guys is to just
take on this idea that men
have the only virtues men
men's behaviors and identities are the
only things of value
that's that's what they're they're
suggesting this is this actually
happened with feminism right feminism
told women in the 1970s that the
male traits the masculine values we're
the only ones with any worth
and all of the specifically female
traits being nurturing
motherly caring for the rocking the
cradle that rules the world that sort
that's actually completely valueless
which is outrageous and not true
but now you're seeing it reach its
apotheosis which is that
now the girls are actually pretending to
be boys what this girl is participating
in
is a cult right that that
is just a cultish behavior where she's
saying no i'm actually my
spirit is actually different myself is
only my spirit now my body
poopy stuff needs to be taken out of the
classroom
because it's confusing people you know
an eighth grade girl just
bashed a school board over this over the
transgender policy because she said this
is harmful to women
specifically because now we have to to
change with boys
in the locker room two years ago i was
told policy 1040 was just an umbrella
philosophy
and you weren't going to allow boys into
the girls locker rooms but here you are
doing just that everyone knows what a
boy is even you
your proposed policies are dangerous and
rooted in sexism
when woke kids asked me if i was a
lesbian or a trans boy
because i cut my hair short it should
tell you these modern identities are
superficial
my guidance counselor's response to my
concerns about bathroom privacy and
safety was
well there are stalls in the bathrooms
now boys are reading erotica in the
classrooms next to girls
and you want to give them access to
girls locker rooms and you want to force
girls to call those boys she you do this
in the name of inclusivity while
ignoring the girls who will pay the
price
your policies choose boys wants over
girls needs
so totally right great stuff uh she's
very you know i i hesitate from playing
you know these viral clips of children
and teenagers because i think
generally speaking i i don't care what
children and teenagers have to say
because by definition they're not
particularly wise or educated
um this however because it was at a
political event it was at a school board
meeting and and she happened to be right
on the issue
then i think it's worth playing uh
however
it goes further than that so much of
this trans
issue is being argued on the right as a
matter of the rights of women you know
the women are losing their bathrooms
they're losing their locker rooms and
now little girls have to change in front
of grown men
just because husky hank decided to call
himself helen last week
that that is insane and it's a good
place to begin
but that's not really the argument
really the the problem here is not that
one group's rights are being infringed
by another group's rights
it's not that well yes men have the
right to pretend that they're women in
the privacy of their own mind but not
in the locker room or whatever the issue
is the reality
it is simply the case
that men who'd put on dresses or not
women you know there was a clip
from jimmy kimmel the other day there's
this clip from jimmy kimmel
and he made a joke about bruce jenner
and
bruce jenner was very offended here's
the joke if you've been keeping up with
caitlyn you know that she
is running for governor of our state
caitlyn jenner karkashian appeared on
the view today
to uh promote that and right off the bat
it did not go great
welcome back to the view caitlyn jenna
well
thank you very much it's always a
pleasure to be with all the ladies and
especially you
whoopi we've been friends forever
let's hear that noise will be made one
more time
yeah and that's just how the interview
started are we sure that isn't donald
trump and a caitlyn jenner wig because i
mean
look at this the resemblance is uncanny
this
they really they've got all the same
kind of moves okay so there there's the
joke and
and uh caitlyn you know i'm calling
caitlyn bruce now not to be mean not to
because i want to be cruel or anything
i think it's cruel to pretend that this
guy is a woman and i think it's cruel to
indulge that delusion
and caitlyn's a girl's name and bruce is
a boy's name and he he's
he's bruce jenner and he might be
confused about that and society might be
confused but i don't think it's good for
anybody
to play into that confusion so bruce
tweets out last night jimmy kimmel
called me donald trump with a wig he
obviously believes that trans women are
simply men with wigs on
where is the outrage from the left or
the lgbt community being woke must be
optional if you're a democrat
that's true it is they don't care about
the double standard and wokeness is not
a standard that i want to go along with
the fact is
trans women are men and wigs and that's
just the fact and that's the reality
and this is part of my fear of a caitlyn
jenner candidacy
is that the right is going to be saying
that democrats are the real transphobes
and we're going to adopt this into
ourselves
it is not simply a case of rights and
one's private matter not infringing on
one's public rights
reality is the point here okay there
some things are real some things are
true we will have standards that either
accord more with that truth or
or do not accord with that truth but
there will be some kind of standards
there will be
language that we all speak there will be
or you'll have total social breakdown
there will be things that we all do and
recognize i would like those things to
be more in line with reality and
sometimes that means
saying no to craziness i'm michael
nolsas the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden continues to malfunction on the
public stage as vladimir putin makes his
aggressive intentions clear that's today
on the ben shapiro show